good morning believe nation today's  message is believed over to UTI awake  misread school TV go I dealt with  rejection several times man you know I'm  saying from the time I started rapping  to the time I went platinum you know  people uh you know I mean I'm one of  those artists that no one ever actually  believes is going to do as well as he  does until he does it you know some  people you uh you think automatically  over yeah that's so and so he's gonna do  enormous numbers but with me as always I  ain't gonna do that much then when I do  it what he did I can't believe so yeah  you know I've always gonna believe it  when I see it type of artist you know  people never believe my success until  they see it I like this prey so keep me  go